- [Woman] No, no it's simple...
- Ahhhh man
- [Man] Ahhhhh
(uptempo music)
- [Auri] 500 million plastic straws
are used in the US everyday.
Many of those straws end up in the ocean
and harm sea life.
Reports predict that by 2050
there will be more plastic
in the ocean than fish.
(cheery music)
- Hi I'm Auri, and all of those facts
make me feel so frustrated and hopeless
and I've been wanting to
do something about this.
So today I'm going around my office
and I'm going to be
asking all of my coworkers
if they'll join me in refusing single
use plastic straws for a whole week.
Hello everyone, hi.
I'm trying to get the whole office
to not use straws for the next seven days.
Would you be down to do that?
- Sure, heck yeah.
- Can I see a show of hands?
Amazing!
- Uhhh unfortunately I don't
think I can at the moment
- I definitely use straws
way too much (laughs)
- Absolutely, I never
use straws for anything
- Great, okay so this
goes a step further...
When you're at a restaurant
and you order a drink
you ask for it without a straw
- Okay what if they give me a straw?
Wow
- Will you pledge to do this
challenge with your signature?
- Yeah, I'm in.
(upbeat groovy music)
- Night has fallen and
by the skin of my teeth
I've managed to collect
a hundred signatures
from people around the office.
Let's see how they do.
- I'm at a movie and I can't
have a straw in my soda
so I'm biting off the end of this red vine
and I'm do it this way.
(cheerful music)
- I despise drinking out of glasses
in public but...
- [Cameraman] Yeah
We're saving the world.
- Sorry
- Now I know this is a paper cup
so I don't know if I'm
really actually helping
the environment by doing this
but at least there's no straw.
- No one is here, I'm going
to be looking in the trashes.
Ooo I see a straw, I see another one.
I am the straw troll and
the trash does not lie.
Muahahahahahaha
- I already failed um, I just forgot...
- We don't need straws (laughter)
- [Camerawoman] We're saving the Earth
- (bleep)
- [Camerawoman] One straw at a time
- I would like a Red Sangria with no straw
- (speaks in unison) No straw, thank you.
- I went to Starbucks,
they gave me a straw
- I'm in a restaurant in Vegas
and I asked for no straw, not
only did you bring a straw...
Two straws for one
drink now for no reason.
Like this is way harder than
it should be and I hate it
like people are dumb.
- Life's not as fun without straws.
- Thank you so much for
coming it's nice to meet you.
- Basically there's 500
million plastic straws
that end up in a landfill every single day
in the US alone so we
really wanted to offset
that madness so we
designed this glass straw.
They had it in the
fifties, we brought it back
and the last 10 to 15 years
we both have been on tour
competing professionally in snowboarding
or watching all the crazy things happening
with our snowpack and climate change
and our plastic waste channels
is a big part of the problem.
Alright so I brought a bunch of straws.
I think we should go pass
them around the office
see if people get stoked.
Yeah ?
- Yes, yay
(together) Cheers
- Goodmorning
- Take your pick, oh yeah
These are stronger than normal glass.
There are porcelain it's like Pyrex.
- I'll go with this one.
- [Woman] There you go
Thank you.
- [Woman] Thank you.
(cheerful music)
- This straw knew me you know (laughs)
- Using our reusable straws
- It's the end of the
challenge how did you do?
- I did it
- You did it?
- I didn't use a straw once.
- Ah really?
Well now I feel like a failure.
I used a straw at least twice.
- These are the accidental
straws this week
and for a hundred people I think
this amount is pretty good considering
that most people use
about two straws a day.
- This week actually turned
out to be super easy.
- It was really hard.
- From now on, I will be
100 percent straw free.
- I'm definitely going
back to just getting
the straws from Starbucks cause
I probably threw this
away about six times.
- The beginning of the week I said that
"Oh I don't use straws".
You don't realize how much you use straws.
- This challenge made me more aware
of how much plastic I was using.
- It kind of made me realize
that there are like small
things that you can change
in your own life to
better the environment.
- I'm so proud of everyone.
(upbeat music)
- If you're watching this
and you're literally
still drinking from straws
you just hate Mother
Earth and it's just fyi.
- [Auri] I mean he said
it, I did not say it.
- I didn't lie, truths only.